in 2008 pixar made a film that would get
the world to fall in love with a plucky
little trash compactor his name
[Laughter]
satan
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that reminds you to put on your
sunday clothes when you feel down and
out no
feels just like yesterday when i was
talking about the 2008 pixar classic
wall-e oh wait it was just
yesterday yeah a few weeks ago while i
was writing a theory further proving how
everyone on board the axiom spacecraft
is unwittingly participating in
cannibalism i learned that apparently
i'm not the only person to see a
sinister underbelly to this heartwarming
story of robot love in space
back in 2017 a reddit user by the name
vexellius had a wild
idea what if wally the robot was satan
and the whole space opera was a
retelling of the biblical story of
humanity's downfall in the garden of
eden now i know what you're thinking
that sounds
insane right i've been doing this a long
time and i have a general sense of what
makes a plausible theory from a
uh bat guano crazy one most of the time
at least like seriously where would
anyone even begin to get an idea like
this well consider the following the
biblical story of the garden of eden
basically boils down to a woman named
eve
getting tricked by satan to deliver the
apple of enlightenment to man this
results in humanity unlocking godlike
knowledge like some sort of dlc patch
god gets mad that suddenly everyone's
embarrassed by their fig leaf attire and
throws him out of paradise
dooming mankind to a lifetime of misery
and hard labor
quote from genesis 3 18 cursed is the
ground because of you
in pain you shall eat of it all the days
of your life thorns and thistles it
shall bring forth for you and you shall
eat the plants of the field by the sweat
of your brow you will eat your food
until you return to the ground
since from it you were taken for dust
you are and two dust you will return
yeah real feel-good story that one but
now let's look at the story of wall-e
which
boils down to a robot named eve
receiving a seedling from wall-e a
seedling that unlocks knowledge in
humanity
these are called farms humans will put
seeds in the ground
and they grow food like pizza
computer define dancing that knowledge
causes the humans to give up their
carefree trip through the cosmos with
unlimited cupcake and a cup refills in
order to return to earth where they're
not only forced to get out of their
hover chairs and use their legs for
literally the first time
ever in their lives but they're
surprised by the fact that this planet
is a bit of a fixer-upper
farming you kids are gonna grow all
kinds of plants
vegetable plants pizza plants once again
humanity's given up paradise for hard
labor
farming out of the harsh wastelands of
the earth and it all starts with
actions of one little robot named wally
filling the satan role by giving eve the
seedling of enlightenment
and all of this is without even
mentioning wally's love of musicals
his favorite hello dolly just saying
wake up here sheeple long story short in
529 words vexellius outlines his magnum
opus a theory that received
widespread coverage across the internet
but does the theory hold up
today we're getting biblical and
psychological to answer the age-old
question
is wall-e satan what is paradise was
humanity lured out of the spaceship of
eden by a little yellow robot in love
all of that and more in today's episode
as we see whether vexellius has a point
ladies and gentlemen i think you all
know what this means it's morty time
leave your theories in the comments
below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode
of morty now when you break this theory
down there are just
some evidence points that can't be
denied wally the movie has a character
named eve the story of creation
also has a character named eve they both
bring back a plant that unlocks
knowledge and humanity getting us to
question our place in the world and
ultimately leave a seemingly idyllic
life in paradise whether that's the
garden of eden or
onboard the axiom i mean doesn't get
much more clear cut than that
so theory confirmed then well almost you
see to me
the maker or breaker of this theory
boils down to one main question
is the axiom really a stand-in for
paradise sure
a lot of the small stuff around the
edges of this theory line up real nicely
but the central question is whether
humanity is
ever really in paradise in the first
place and what i mean by that is whether
the axiom as a cruise line or spaceship
is able to fulfill all of humanity's
needs in the same way that the garden of
eden
is said to be paradise in the biblical
retelling so that then
seems to be our best place to start the
garden of eden was introduced in the
book of genesis the first book of the
hebrew bible and the christian old
testament there are certainly plenty of
passing mentions of it elsewhere and
obviously tons of artwork along the way
but in general we're going to try to
stick to the original source materials
description which uh
shockingly doesn't give you a whole lot
to work with there are only 10 short
verses
actually describing the garden itself
four of them are dedicated to its rivers
and a solid
zero of them talk about what day to day
life in the garden was actually like
or even meant to be like i mean here let
me just show you
this is pretty much all you have to go
on quote and out of the ground the lord
god made to spring up every tree that is
pleasant to the sight and good for food
the tree of life was in the midst of the
garden and the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil blah blah blah here's all
that boring river stuff and uh here's
the rest the lord god took the man and
put him in the garden of eden to work it
and keep it
yada yada don't eat the apple stupid oh
yeah and then there's the last verse
where they run around naked final quote
and the man and his wife were both naked
and were not ashamed that's it that's
what you got
not a lot to go off of so we're gonna
have to read between the lines here
basically what we can infer is what
you'd expect from years of seeing this
story retold a bunch of times eden is a
beautiful garden where there is no shame
endless food
and pure innocence god's big issue with
the apple of enlightenment is that
suddenly humanity is granted knowledge
of good and evil
implying that paradise is a place of
blissful ignorance to the bad
in the world so does the axiom fit the
bill well yeah the people don't seem to
need jobs they get unlimited beverage
refills and they're carted around by
neat hover chairs that prevent them from
ever having to walk around
the temperature is always 72 degrees
they have no knowledge of whether it's
actually day or night and robots take
care of their children
just like god springing up every tree
that is pleasant to the sight and good
for food we have robots and screens able
to deliver whatever we want to watch and
eat
assuming of course that it's not ground
up human flesh like i've guessed in
previous theories
essentially it's a world where your
biggest decision on a day-to-day basis
is whether you should go to the virtual
golf course or order another hot dog
nobody has to worry about putting ikea
furniture together and they can chat
with their best buds while getting their
hair done by polite robots who are very
complimentary
this does seem to be living the dream as
presumably there's no poverty
no war no stressful work schedules no
dangerous weather conditions to
interrupt your game of virtual tennis
according to the commentary on the
wall-e dvd director andrew stanton said
that the people aboard the axiom
after hundreds of years of being
immobile have regressed into big babies
with shrinking
arms and legs and ears that aren't fully
formed again if paradise is truly
defined to be a state of perpetual
innocence while being supervised by an
all-powerful being then yeah
being able to return to the state of a
baby in your hover chair while the ai
cares for you
is the literal definition of paradise as
if all of these parallels weren't enough
eating the apple is the event that
introduces the idea of death into the
creation myth
in genesis 2 17 god warns adam and eve
quote but of the tree of knowledge of
good and evil you shall not eat for in
the day that you eat you shall
die likewise on board the axiom people
live long lives when we first meet
captain mccree we scan past a wall of
portraits
five people who served as captain long
before him each with an average tenure
of around 133 years
implying that people on board the ship
live a long long time
adding up the captain's terms for these
five people and you get yourself
a whopping 666 years
666.
wait hold on let me do that math again
248 minus
2774 minus adding this and carry the one
and you get
six six six
it's the sign of the beast the devil's
numbers i mean
that is super weird i i don't even know
what to say about that but it's right
there it's right there on the wall and
it feels really intentional like you
don't just
randomly stumble on that number captain
mccree's tenure could have started
whenever
the odds of it landing 666 years after
the axiom's voyage started is just uh
it's uncanny maybe the animators put
that in as a joke or
maybe as a sign that this theory is
actually right on the money
666 years after the voyage starts mccree
becomes captain
and it's on his watch that wall-e comes
to cause the fall of humanity back to
earth
or maybe just maybe it means the exact
opposite the axiom isn't paradise it's
actually
h-e-double hockey stix for as much of a
carefree life as the axiom seems to
offer on the surface if you look a bit
closer you start to see some cracks in
its civilization
we hear passengers say look i'm tired of
having the same argument over and over
well another mutters something about
jealousy
and let's not forget that when we first
meet our main human mary she's talking
to her friend about this
we get hints that there's jealousy
arguments bad dates on the ship which
means that problems
still exist here also the passengers
aboard the axiom have been
so engrossed in social media
advertisements and consumerism that
they've completely forgotten
about the joys of face-to-face
interactions and touch the people aboard
the ship don't create
anything they don't appreciate what they
have their dependence on technology has
made them impatient and angry
across all psychological research there
are three things that time and time
again
are proven to make people happy close
personal relationships a challenging job
or hobby and helping others through
pro-social behavior
that's it that's the secret to raising
your overall happiness meter and those
are three things that are decidedly
lacking from the axiom and research has
shown that the things the axiom does
offer
like more stuff doesn't move the needle
at all except for very short temporary
spikes and happiness you'll notice that
in all the shots of people on board
there are never shots of people smiling
of them laughing
there is no emotion on board except
being numb
in short the axiom is in paradise it's
hell tearing people away from their
loved ones forcing them into a constant
cycle of consumption
anesthetizing them with a constant
onslaught of screens so there are no
hobbies or challenging activities
immersing them in a self-centered
wasteland
even the garden of eden knew the dangers
of being completely complacent in
genesis 2 verse 15 we learned that god
placed adam and eden so he could take
care of the gardens and trees
it means that adam was forced to do
actual work like pruning and cultivating
the land
while he was in paradise sure the axiom
might have trappings of paradise
limitless food perpetually sunny skies
being weighted on hand and foot a
carefree lifestyle but even if you strip
away the consumerist dystopia that it is
that's not what humanity
actually wants it's not what we need
that's not what science has shown
psychologically makes us happy we thrive
on being challenged by having agency in
our lives by learning
by overcoming and by doing that for the
community of people around us
so what does all of this mean for the
walius satan theory
well i think it's great the parallels
are all absolutely there
even down to the devilish 666 hidden in
the captain's quarters which gotta admit
still really creepy pixar come to think
of it has anyone noticed that detail
before
sure someone must have it someone didn't
come up in my research it was just as i
was writing this theory i'm like wait
666 oh that's
weird man and if you define paradise how
the garden of eden did which is being
innocent and naive to the cares of the
world then the axiom
yeah comes pretty darn close so on that
front i'd say theory confirmed
wall-e is the unintentional serpent that
brings about the fall of humanity but
thing is
paradise is more than just innocents and
cupcake slushies paradise comes with an
assumption of happiness
of agency and the people on board the
axiom aren't happy
they're placated they're numb they're
distracted they're in an
endless stasis that is not paradise in
fact it's pretty much the exact opposite
looking at it from that perspective
wall-e is the one that saves us from
h-e-double hockey sticks so that would
make wall-e uh
what noah moses jesus yeah it's probably
that one isn't it
wall-e is jesus overturning merchant
card tables with his little hydraulic
arms don't know how people feel about
that one anyway
here's the long and short of this morty
it's a great theory that for as absurd
as it sounds
absolutely holds up sure i can nitpick
here and there about perspectives and
what does or doesn't qualify as paradise
but in my book it's about as close as
some of the strongest theories get
so consider the wall-e is satan theory
theorist approved vexela's theory
finishes by saying quote it wouldn't be
surprising if generations later the
people in wally's universe start telling
tales of a time when they lived in a
place of eternal bliss until a tempter
gave a woman named eve a plant which led
to humanity's downfall
honestly i could see that happening too
but uh they'll probably skip over the
part where they had to suck down the
bodies of dead ship-goers as their main
source of protein
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut
[Music]
you